[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
i just wanted to make this brief video
to further discuss the upcoming
fantastic beasts films
of which two have been released and
three are still yet to come
in 2016 we got fantastic beasts and
where to find them
the first installments of the five-part
film series that introduced us to a
wizarding world
during a different time placing an
emphasis on all sorts of new
and never-before-seen characters
creatures and places
we saw the wizarding world in america
for the first time
creatures like nifflers new magic and
even a new antagonist
gelat grindelwald in 2018 the follow-up
to the first film
in the second part of the five film
series was released
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald the crimes of grindelwald
expanded on this new world further but
in order to make things even more
interesting
began to incorporate elements of the
wizarding world that we already knew and
loved
in the form of characters places and
dialogue the film ended on a pretty big
cliffhanger
and the films were clearly not released
without the intention
of completing the five part series as so
many questions remained unanswered when
the credits began to roll
since then fans have been patiently
awaiting another film
the third and middle part of the five
part series but the thing is
they've been waiting for a long time the
initial release date
for the film was supposed to be november
of this year 2020
but due to unforeseen circumstances
kovid the film was pushed back
a full year and though we were provided
with this new release date by warner
brothers
things still felt a bit rocky when it
came to the fantastic beasts franchise
and i for one still wasn't completely
confident that the film would be
delivered as promised
this is for a number of reasons the
first reason being the controversy
surrounding multiple people involved
with the films and the second reason
being the negative attention
that was directed at the films that had
already been released
fantastic beasts one and two didn't
crash and burn but did they live up to
the harry potter films
definitely not however it turns out that
this break was actually much needed for
jk rowling
and warner brothers as the negative
attention and extra time that they were
given
prompted a screenplay rewrite that would
include harry potter alumnus
steve cloves who was an integral part of
the harry potter films
so where do we sit now earlier this
month there were rumors floating around
that fantastic beasts 3 had begun
filming and photos were even linked
online
which appeared to depict a fantastic
beast 3 set
however warner brothers and the actors
were still relatively silent on this
matter
until now just the other day eddie
redmayne aka newt's commander
the star of fantastic beasts confirmed
that the film has begun filming
he also confirmed that we will be seeing
his co-stars johnny depp
and ezra miller who've been dealing with
all sorts of controversy as of late
this should come as consoling news to
harry potter and fantastic beasts fans
as this statement officially dispels the
rumors surrounding the film franchise
being shut down altogether
coveted restrictions on the film
industry that prevented companies from
filming
were loosened in may but we still didn't
see any fantastic beast sets
which made people worry a little in a
statement eddie redmayne confirmed that
filming officially started in london
two weeks ago and that the cast and crew
are adhering to
strict coronavirus protocols it's a
whole new normal
testing frequently masks and i wondered
actually
whether the masks would affect
creativity in some ways
maybe that was a bit ignorant but i just
thought as humans
do we need interaction to spark from
each other what is really reassuring
is that it is a different process but it
still feels like it's fizzing
and that everyone is working at the top
of their game with the new harry potter
game on the way hogwarts legacy
and a new film coming out next year
there are lots of good things coming
for harry potter fans look out for
fantastic beasts 3 in theaters
november 12th 2021 and that's it for
this video
what do you guys think we can expect to
see from the third film what do you
think they changed during the screenplay
rewrite
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
your wizard harry
you